all right guys
bang bang alex is back i think this is
the third time we're doing this
uh thank you so much for doing this sir
it's an honor and a privilege to be on
absolutely all right for those that
haven't listened to the earlier episodes
just give us a quick kind of two minutes
your background
and uh what you guys are doing at the
human rights foundation
yeah so i've been at hrf as we like to
call it since 2007
and we are a non-profit that focuses on
helping people who live under
authoritarian countries around the world
by our latest research that's about 4.3
billion people in 95 countries
ranging from cuba to saudi arabia to
china to turkey to russia to zimbabwe
who don't have the same rights and
freedoms as we do in open societies
uh like we do more or less here in the
united states or the eu or japan
so the world's kind of split into these
two different kinds of societies
and at href we figure out how to help
the dissidents and journalists and
troublemakers
uh who who live in those societies and
in the first two
shows that i came on i got you know i
remember we talked about my work at href
more generally and then
you know we also talked about the rise
of increasing restrictions on civil
liberties in the time of uh
sort of the pandemic times right
absolutely
and so since then it seems like uh one
people have woken up to like hey there's
a lot of bad stuff going on around the
world and uh
there are some things that we need to
focus on from a privacy standpoint uh
but also
too is uh there's been financial
resources both donated to
human rights foundation and then you
guys have started to hand out uh some of
these um
grants if you want uh to call them that
and so let's just start with kind of
like how do you guys
think about managing resources and where
you can use your time and energy
uh versus when you can use capital and
kind of how that
framework or that decision gets made
sure well we are a again a non-profit
501c3
uh in the eyes of law here in the united
states based in new york
incorporated there in 2005 and
we have roughly a you know it ranges but
let's just say
this year we're going to raise about 14
million dollars so we have a significant
budget we have programs all around the
world events all around the world
um we have a special relationship with
bitcoin
because we started receiving bitcoin
donations in 2014.
and i remember distinctly one of our
donors at that time was like hey can i
pay for one of my
conference tickets to go to one of your
events in bitcoin and we were like
what the hell is bitcoin i mean we had
sort of heard about it and some
activists had tried to introduce
me to it here before um but we weren't
very deep in
and we were like fine so we set up a
wallet uh it was an early coinbase
wallet at the time right
and we started to take bitcoin donations
and those were really great for us and
we started to think about
what that could mean for the future of
the organization and
bitcoin's been very good been very good
to the human rights foundation
so in the past year as we've kind of
seen
the patronage model of bitcoin grow
and what i mean by that is there's no
pre-mine in bitcoin like most
cryptocurrencies have
like a set allocated amount of tokens
that get like locked up at the beginning
for use for development like it's like a
dev fund or a pre-mine or whatever you
want to call it
bitcoin doesn't have that so it relies
on the community it
relies on the world to fund its
development and
over its first decade that was largely
done you know voluntarily
right but over the last couple years
you've seen
large companies start to really get
involved with funding core development
which is fantastic
um but we at the human rights foundation
saw both a
not only our kind of like close tie to
bitcoin in terms of what it is as a tool
for human rights and
how it's been helpful to us and how we'd
want to maybe get back to it
but also the fact that we as a
non-profit
may be able to encourage other
non-profits to get involved in helping
bitcoin maybe we could be that catalyst
because at the end of the day if
corporations
are the only ones supporting bitcoin
development
that's not ideal um it's it's
it's not a huge threat because
ultimately the core developers are going
to do whatever they want
right i mean you know if if bitmex or
if you know one of these other exchanges
decides to give a grant to a developer
there's no strings attached like that
developer is pretty much going to do
whatever they want
but it's it's a little scary to think
about a world in the future where it's
only the corporations
giving the funding because hey maybe the
developer says screw you i don't want to
do what you're telling me to do on
bitcoin
but if all the corporations are aligned
with a particular agenda
and all of them want something and the
developers are like no
and that funding gets pulled that could
put us in a tricky situation
and we've seen that before in bitcoin
where pretty much all the corporations
in bitcoin
wanted to do something that the users
didn't want to do this was of course
back in 2017 and if you look at the new
york agreement which is still on the dcg
website
they've got basically every corporation
in bitcoin wanted to do segwit2x
and make make the block size much larger
through a hard fork
and that was rejected by the users that
summer right through the user activated
soft fork
so a lot of great stuff in there but the
big lesson essentially is that
um the users decided to say that
corporations don't control bitcoin
um now fast forward to today again i
think it's great that all these
corporations are supporting bitcoin
developers it's fabulous
but it would be ideal if there were more
than just corporations supporting it
so mit has a particular um
outs out you know they have an outfit
called the the uh
dcf i believe um sorry the dci
uh digital currency initiative which is
great but they're like the only major
university that has that
so what we want to see is a world where
there's like tons of universities
funding bitcoin work
as well as non-profits maybe the aclu in
the future
the eff etc got it and so
basically what you guys have done is
you've gone out and you've found people
who are working on bitcoin core
development
um and talk through maybe the process of
like how do you find these individuals
how do you vet them how do you actually
make the decision as to
who you're going to give a grant to and
who you're not sure
well we with the bitcoin development
fund we are both supporting
core development uh meaning developers
who are literally working on the core
project
as well as people who are building tools
to make bitcoin more private
uh more resilient and more usable so
it's a little bit more of a wide range
than maybe some other projects that are
like really focusing on core development
um
we have a fabulous network of uh
bitcoiners that care deeply about
privacy and freedom
and when we we basically have it set up
so people email us all the time with
ideas that they want to get funded
we also have people we trust that we
call up and we ask hey
you know got any good ideas lately of
people we can fund
um so we basically create short lists
out of both
public application and private
consulting with
uh experts in the space right and
then you know we kind of take a look at
like
are these people already being funded um
and you know would funding them make a
difference right would it would it
really say something would it be
emblematic in some way
and the five gifts we've given so far in
the first six months of the fund
i think all match that the first gift we
gave was to chris belcher
who's working on something called coin
swap
which is going to basically allow people
to like swap their bitcoin in a way that
chain analysis can't understand
right and we thought that was a very
fitting
thing to try to support because if
bitcoin can be a privacy tool then it's
going to be a much better tool for human
rights activists right so that's what we
came out with with our first
gift we also supported a couple other
people
who are working to make your phone a
better tool
for interacting with both the lightning
network and
a bitcoin node if you run one at home
right so we created
grants for a couple projects working on
uh
basically your ability to to use your
full node or use a lightning network
from your phone
um we also gave a gift out to someone
working on something called join market
which is a coin
join implementation which is really
freaking hard to use
so the guy's trying to make it more like
usable for people and then finally our
latest gift was to gloria zhao who's a
graduating senior at berkeley computer
science
core developer who's going to be working
on basically what we call in bitcoin the
mempool
she's going to be working on upgrading
the processing power of bitcoin
so that it can do more and so that
complicated transactions like for
example
when you come into or out of lightning
onto the main chain so that that's
cheaper and more efficient to do so
that's how we've kind of
set it up so far we have a lot of um
desire to fund projects also out in the
developing world
so that we've gotten some interesting
proposals so far there
so i think you can expect our attention
to shift
in that direction but generally speaking
we are excited to be funding people who
are making bitcoin more
more private and a better human rights
tool and that's that's why kind of it
matters to us
and what are the sizes of these grants
are we talking ten thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars like
what exactly is the ballpark right well
it's interesting because uh
most of the gifts have been given out in
bitcoin so it depends on how they've
been spent but
you know uh in june when we made our
first gift it was denominated you know
it's always denominated in u.s
it was denominated in usd at first right
so
we gave a 50 000 gift to chris belcher
well um that gift is now worth uh
you know probably close to 120 000
you know what i mean so um you know look
giving gifts out to core developers is
wonderful for for that particular reason
um and a lot of them want bitcoin right
um
and and a lot of the people who donate
to the bitcoin development fund
um do it in bitcoin so it's just an easy
thing for us to handle
uh other gifts we've given are in the
we're in like the one bitcoin range
uh and they were supposed to be like
kind of like small but meaningful gifts
of encouragement right and
and mainly acknowledgement because
whenever hr fund somebody they get they
get some attention in the media et
cetera et cetera
but hey a one bitcoin gift is becoming
pretty serious
um and then the most recent one again
was a fifty thousand dollar
usd denominated grant in bitcoin um
now the latest gift we we get a lot of
like
um different kinds of donations for
anyone who knows about running a
non-profit
um when you report uh to the government
your list of donors which you have to do
you have to disclose them if they're
over a certain amount
but if they're little small ones you
don't right so we get all kinds of
lightning donations
on our website at ahrefs.org we get we
get a lot of interesting small donations
we don't know
anything about these people right um
it's just it's great to see them coming
in
um but the larger ones you know usually
those people are seeking a tax uh
write-off right because if you donate to
hrf um we can furnish you with
a tax deduction right um because we're a
501c3 charity
so the latest uh gift coming in is gonna
be
uh from from gemini from cameron and
tyler and team
over at gemini um and they're gonna be
giving they're giving fifty thousand
dollars
denominated in bitcoin actually which is
exciting um
and we're going to be giving that those
gifts out in q1 uh
again probably the projects that are
kind of uh
working out in the developing world is
is an idea we have
got it and so like what is that
conversation like in terms of cameron
and tyler deciding
to do that actually uh interesting story
so good friend peter mccormick
friend of yours horrible guy worst guy
ever peter if you're listening to this
you're horrible
constant debate between the two about
who's better right he's better
he's always better it's it's good for us
to have both of you guys
let's put it that way but peter had the
twins on
okay and he was talking to him about
bitcoin he was kind of pushing them on
hey
why haven't you guys made any public
announcements yet on
funding bitcoin development and he did
the same with brian armstrong
and peter's been very effective well i
think we could we can really give
peter a round of applause here because
after doing the show with peter brian
and coinbase announced that they were
going to be doing some of this support
right
and after doing the show with peter uh
cameron and tyler came out
and said they were going to do two
things so first they created what's
what they're calling an opportunity fund
which is fabulous and
they gave uh they announced they're
going to give 200 000
denominated in bitcoin 200 000 usd but
in bitcoin
uh 150 to fund a fellowship at something
called brink
which is what john newberry is starting
which is basically like a grad school
for bitcoiners
you can think of like you go to
undergrad you get you get good enough
and then you can go to brink and you can
spend a year under the tutelage of like
world-class bitcoin experts and you can
like do your work in a way that's very
guided
and hrf thought was thinks that's very
valuable so we're like a founding
partner
uh at brink but basically the gemini
folks have said
we're gonna give 150 to brink to
establish a fellowship or we get 50 to
hrf
okay so i think that's a great way to go
it's going to accomplish a couple
different things and it's going to put
the decision-making power
of who who gets the gift in in in
someone else's hands which i think is a
really classy thing to do for a
corporation
um so i think that's a wonderful kind of
way forward and we're gonna see
more and more people get involved in
this and the crazy part is
they're doing it out of self-interest um
like it's an altruistic thing to give a
gift of course right
we're in philanthropy right however
the cool part about bitcoin is it's got
a lot of game theory in it
and it's like good for these companies
to give to core developers because it's
great pr for them
but like it's it's something that the
community regardless of what we think
about coinbase right
we are going to universally applaud them
supporting core developers
so even if there's a lot of bitcoiners
who are like say this thing about
bitcoin base or another or people
others that that are like angry you know
with coinbase about something else like
you may have seen in new york times
recently
um it doesn't really matter but if they
fund core development
that's really putting their money where
their mouth is um so
what's interesting is that it is kind of
like this
almost unilaterally
you know uh or unanimously
considered a good thing and it's like
it's something they can do
you know with self-interest it's not
just an altruistic gift
it's something they're gonna want to do
um but what's funny is nobody's forcing
them no one has a gun to these companies
head saying hey
you could you should fund bitcoin core
development they realize on their own
that they should and they need to
which is again one of these really
interesting things about bitcoin's game
theory that that i love to follow
and so when we think about corporations
supporting bitcoin uh obviously
they have a financial interest if
bitcoin succeeds many of their
businesses will succeed as well
right there is kind of what i'll call
the marketing support talking about
bitcoin going on
uh the media doing all that kind of
stuff there is
uh the infrastructure support which
they're providing that literally they're
in the for-profit business of building
infrastructure around it
uh but really what you're talking about
is like the direct financial support of
those building
the uh protocols and and uh other pieces
of infrastructure around it
is that pretty much the totality of how
a corporation can support bitcoin are
there other ideas as well as things that
they can be doing in order to
kind of push forward progress and
innovation here
well by their very nature
these organizations are onboarding users
and are growing bitcoin in many ways
but the most important way to support
bitcoin
is by supporting core developers um at
the end of the day the corporations the
and and the uh silicon valley companies
and the
wall street investors and the chinese
miners none of these people control
bitcoin
um they can compete
to process transactions you know they
can get a bunch of money together buy a
bunch of mining equipment and try to
mine
that doesn't give them control over the
network they can build
impressive large companies out in
silicon valley or in new york city or
whatever
to try and allow users to invest in
bitcoin to allow users to buy and trade
bitcoin
also wonderful does not give them the
power to control bitcoin
the the the way that bitcoin is
controlled is through this sort of like
social consensus
and once the consensus goes in a certain
direction the people who have to
implement those changes
are the core developers right so these
are again these are people who
traditionally
have done this like work in a thankless
way it's like yellman's work you know
they they weren't it was not glamorous
for a long time
they weren't they still aren't being
paid a lot compared to like what you'd
make as an end these are scientists
these are engineers right so
you have to think about the life
decision you make and gloria who we
supported
has a great appearance on steven
lavera's podcast where she talks about
this like
you know her traditional life arc would
have put her at google or something
where she'd be making like huge amounts
of money doing in software engineering
so to work in bitcoin you necessarily
you're you're kind of taking a hit there
on your salary you're not making the
same as you'd make
building some ai surveillance system at
google or at alipay or whatever right
um but you are like doing something
really good for the world by working
on this decentralized money project so
at the end of the day i think
you know these businesses are
by their very nature contributing to
bitcoin by growing the user base sure
but the most important thing they can do
to help bitcoin long-term like we're
talking decades from now
um and the most the best signal they can
send to the bitcoin community that they
care about bitcoin
is by supporting the developers yeah and
what about nonprofits you know
obviously you guys are kind of leading
the charge in terms of
uh kind of showing people that there is
a way to
do philanthropic work but have it
focused on
privacy technology um and kind of this
monetary freedom
movement is the hope that you can pull
other non-profits in to kind of
um you know do the same work uh or do
you think this is something where you
guys will be at it alone for a while
well um obviously the
the the major contributor on this front
so so far has been dci
at mit uh under a university sort of
umbrella
but they're they're sort of um very tied
to the mit name
and you know contributions made to them
have to to go to this certain route
and it's a wonderful way for bitcoin
development to start
but again it's it's it's too limited so
we were looking at that and saying wow
that's really like one of the only ways
people could
support bitcoin um through a non-profit
uh beyond that there was like before we
started our fund there was not like a
like an organization you could donate to
in the united states that was a 51c3
where you could get a tax write-off and
support bitcoin just didn't exist
so when we started that what we
were doing again was like hoping to
encourage more people now
uh in a in great with great news there's
numerous new bitcoin non-profits coming
into existence
brink which i mentioned will be doing
fellowships for core development
um they are also seeking 501c3 support
um which is great there's another
initiative that's
kind of under wraps but they have a
twitter account and there's been some
talk about it called
openstats um which will be hopefully
also a way that you can make like
non-prof a nonprofit where you can make
donations directly to developers working
on stuff
but if you think about think about how
early we are i mean think about
human rights or uh you know taxes and
financial freedom or whatever
think about how many nonprofits and
lobby groups are active in those spaces
we're talking
if if not dozens hundreds and you know
if not hundreds
these dozens and dozens in both of these
spaces you know with bitcoin
you're talking like less than what you
can count on one hand right
so we're so so early and we hope to
encourage and inspire like many many
more actors to get involved in this
space
it really needs to be like a diverse
space um
so that when the time comes when there
is like the next big
like war over bitcoin soul right um
which which we saw in 2017 where all
these miners and corporations wanted to
do one thing and the users wanted to do
the other
you know we want it to be set up in such
a way that if there is another war
maybe it's the us government says hey
all you companies in the crypto space
you got to do x
you know and that would be bad for
bitcoin well if they all
decide to pull their funding for
developers for or are forced to
we need to make sure that the funding
could continue to flow
right so we want a globally diverse not
just us
but a globally diverse support network
for bitcoin
developers that that should be like a
goal of the next decade
uh for everybody in this community
absolutely
and when you think about um kind of the
ways that people can help
core developers obviously there's the
financial means are there other things
people can do if they're listening to
this and they say hey i want to
uh pitch in but either i don't have a
lot of money i don't want to donate
what else can people do or is it just
the best path forward is to uh
kind of use financial means in order to
support these folks
yeah i mean obviously the most important
thing is to fund them so that they can
do the work they want to do
you know we're finally getting to the
point where a lot of them can spend full
time
you know are employed full-time which is
wonderful
um but there are certainly other ways
look if you're a fintech company
or you're in payments in employees or
perhaps your technical employees to
learn more about how bitcoin works
just from an educational curiosity point
of view why don't you pull
a bitcoin core developer in for a q a
with your company
and he or she can tell you about what
they do and it's it's really interesting
i mean again these are scientists these
are these are computer scientists these
are engineers working
uh with hard on hard math to figure out
how to make more
bitcoin more efficient more private more
scalable more robust
i mean these are some really epic
engineering challenges that they're
solving
and if we can give them the spotlight
it'll encourage other people to want to
get involved
i think one issue with bitcoin
development is that it's just not very
diverse and it's not very big in terms
of people working on it
and that's largely because most people
just don't know how exciting or cool it
is
um so if we talk about recruitment hr
etc if more and more people
you know out there on linkedin and you
know you know in in
corporate programming environments and
people listening to this show
you know if you want to shine a light on
what makes bitcoin tick
you should bring in some of these
developers and have them explain it
to your to your employees you know from
their perspective
you all may not agree with them you may
not agree with bitcoin's monetary policy
or
its privacy enhancements or uh the way
that it really
seems to be like disturbingly sovereign
you know maybe
you're a little off put by some of these
things but i'm telling you
it's really fun to talk to these
developers and learn about why they
decided to
commit their lives to this project it's
fascinating
and that that would be a big
non-monetary way you could help
i love that idea there's been a lot of
talk recently about
kind of the privacy features uh and
versus corporate support right kind of
um
a breakdown of hey if corporations want
to use it
uh then they're going to need to uh
have a reduction in the privacy features
of bitcoin
um there's a lot of people who think
that's a great idea there's even more
people who think that's a horrible idea
um and there's this whole group of
people who are very uh
privacy focused and that's part of what
drove them uh to be interested in
bitcoin
how do you think about that uh kind of
balance or
um face-off if you will between uh
privacy and corporations
yeah i mean in a lot of ways i think
where in bitcoin
we had the last big standoff between
corporations and kind of users
cypherpunks we'll say um again was in
2017 and it was
it was over this idea of scaling right
and the corporations wanted to scale
in this very straightforward way that
would make the blocks bigger and
therefore they could
process more transactions and make more
money and unload more people to bitcoin
really fast right that was like their
idea and the users were like whoa whoa
whoa
if you do that we're going to ruin the
decentralization proposition of bitcoin
it won't be sovereign anymore
you know and it won't be that remarkable
freedom tool
and ultimately the user's one in that in
that conflict which is something to be
grateful for
almost almost every day here the next
big one i think is going to be around
like
kyc or know your customer uh information
as well as the the general idea of
privacy and
my perspective of course comes from the
work i do with the human rights
foundation
so what's very important to understand
there's there's kind of like two bubbles
of conversation
the big bubble that you and i are often
exposed to or that we live in rather
and that all of our interactions mostly
on
whether it's linkedin or facebook or
conferences or emailers or
what we see on tv or whatever we're all
part of this like western bubble
like the krugman bubble right like new
york london tokyo like
our financial systems pretty much work i
mean
as you and i both know people a lot of
people in the bitcoin community think
uh not very highly of these western
financial systems
and we can poke a lot of holes in them
but more or less like they have produced
like currencies that are valuable like
the dollar the euro the end these people
want these things
they tend to be much more valuable and
stable than the rest
right and it's very easy to open a line
of credit in the west
it's very easy to take out a loan um
there's like fdic insurance like
the government is not going to be so
brazen about just stealing your money
like generally speaking we live under
like this luxurious system
where things are pretty good here right
out in the west but that's not the case
for like most people in this
in this world and that's kind of
something i've learned through my work
at the human rights foundation
like the average person doesn't live in
the eu or the us that's like less than a
billion people right
so we have the lucky billion who live in
the u.s eu in japan
who enjoy a lot of financial privileges
and freedoms i mean look
they're not perfect and they're getting
uh restricted every day i mean we have
things like the bank secrecy act and
the travel rule coming here in the
united states and things are a lot worse
than you might imagine
but still they're so much better than
what they're like in
like saudi arabia or russia or turkey or
china where most humans live out there
who aren't in the lucky billion and i
think what
what what i'm getting at is that there
are uses for bitcoin um
or rather people use bitcoin in
different ways around the world
and the main way that we've been exposed
in the bubble here in the lucky billion
to bitcoin is as is as a speculative
store
value right as an investment that can
make you rich okay
and you know what it's done a pretty
good job of that of course for a lot of
people and that's what's leading
paul tudor jones and michael saylor and
all these different corporate boards and
corporate treasuries to pop up and start
adding bitcoin right
they think it's going to be a good
savings mechanism
in a time of turbulence and in a time of
monetary
expansion and that's completely
legitimate and accurate it will be okay
however that's just like one of the many
things people use bitcoin for right
globally you have to remember people use
bitcoin for remittances for getting
around sanctions
um and before you make judgments about
the sanctions thing
put yourself in the shoes of like a 23
year old iranian okay he or she
they didn't vote for their government
they didn't you know they don't control
the dictatorship that runs iran who's
doing all these evil things
and because of the decisions of a bunch
of thugs
that they didn't elect you know they can
no longer buy apple stuff
or connect to international payment
services so it's unfair for them
and bitcoin allows them to connect to
the international economy that's amazing
right
it allows them to save not in the real
the real is a currency
in iran that has been completely
destroyed by the government there um
through all despite the fact that they
have all this oil they've destroyed the
local currency by
spending on wars and propping up syria
and god knows what else right not
helping the people
but bitcoin allows iranians to escape
into another currency they can't get
dollars dollars are really hard to get
there
and we're not talking about some little
slice of the earth
70 million people okay you can say the
same thing about venezuela okay another
30 million people
you can say the same thing about nigeria
in many ways that's another several
hundred million people so
it starts to add up and and again
hyperinflation and being cut off from
the international financial system
and you know even just really generally
really high inflation
like maybe not hyper at 50 per month but
you know 10
20 like you see in turkey argentina
again this is much more normal for an
average human on this planet than people
think so again we live in the lucky
billion we live in our little bubble
we think the only possible use case for
bitcoin in many ways is this like
savings mechanism
or as an investment class right but
again a lot of people around the world
use it for a lot of other things
whether it's remittances or getting
around sanctions or just even just
preserving their wealth
against like a thuggish government so
i think we need to open our eyes a
little bit and think globally about what
bitcoin means
and at the end of the day it needs
privacy because again for all of our
friends who live out there outside the
lucky billion
they need financial privacy it's not
good enough that they can save their
money they need to make sure the
government doesn't know they have it
okay
and that's a moral thing um we're
talking people who live in countries
uh like sudan or like china
where there's like literally communists
and dictators who run their country
you know they need a way to save
privately okay
so i understand that companies want to
make regulators safe when they talk to
them they want them to feel comfortable
oh bitcoin's like you know you can track
it and
it's totally transparent and it's going
to be cool i know that's part of their
sales pitch
but that's not going to be the case
already there's
a lot of ways to use bitcoin in a way
that's that's quite private
and i wanted to go into some of them at
some point in our conversation but
you know it's not going to to to
just naively assume that bitcoin is this
toy for you uh to to invest in and
that's it
um the world's much bigger than that i
hope that's an okay point
pomp i i think that's a perfect point
what are the ways that
um you either one see people using
bitcoin in a private manner today or two
you think will become kind of the
prevalent ways that uh that bitcoin's
used uh privately
yeah so i'm i just recently uh wrote up
uh
a long paper which will be in the cato
journal this
winter uh academic paper and it looks at
the social role of cash
because again when satoshi invented
bitcoin if you read the white paper you
know
it's about creating digital cash right
you think about what digital cash does
two main things that that's that you and
i and our and our parents and
grandparents
in the modern age have used cash for one
is savings so outside of the bank
savings we withdraw the cash
and people make fun of like oh you have
your savings under your bed
well a lot of people around the world
still keep their savings under their bed
especially again people who don't live
in the lucky billion people who live out
there in different countries around the
world
they save in american dollars they save
in greenbacks like hidden somewhere in
their property this is like really
really common right
so cash is used for savings okay cash is
also used for private and small payments
right
so i think in this essay i try to
break this down and show that so far
bitcoin has actually done quite a good
job on the savings aspect it's been a
good store of value for a lot of people
around the world
um especially over the last five years
compared to the first five years um
it's also like better as many of your
guests have pointed out it's better than
gold in many ways it can teleport
it's easily verifiable uh it's much more
secure much more safe all these things
so in many ways bitcoin does make a
pretty good store of value
a great one actually um however
we have to think about its future and
can it do private and small payments
right
um the privacy piece is ongoing the good
news is bitcoin's programmable
money it's not like ossified it
continues to evolve right
and one of the big reasons why there was
that big war in 2017
about how to scale bitcoin where the
corporations wanted to do one thing the
users wanted to do the other
the users wanted to do it through this
thing called segwit or segregated
witness and
it's very technical but we'll just leave
it at this segwit really allowed
lightning to become a big thing in
bitcoin right to actually come into
existence and be what it is today
and if you think about privacy and
financial privacy and payments that you
and i make
right when you make a payment in cash
the merchant doesn't know anything about
you they just know that your payment is
good they don't know your home address
or what you bought last or what your
payment history was right
when you make a payment with bitcoin
they don't they also don't know any of
that stuff they just know that the
payment was good
um the thing is as you and i both know
bitcoin payments can be they can be
pricey the fees are going to get higher
and higher in the future
and there's like things that people can
do to track bitcoin
transactions on the blockchain so by by
activating segwit and giving birth to
lightning and popularizing lightning
i mean we've now had
millions of payments been made in
bitcoin but off the chain
so in a way that like no surveillance
company can like watch
they're not stored forever in public
view right if i send you bitcoin today
even if no one else knows the addresses
are linked to us that payment will
remain in public view forever right
but you i could also make payment and
lightning to you and that's not so
that's like a major major privacy
upgrade that we've seen
right there are a couple others that are
out there
um your audience should probably be
aware of an upgrade coming soon called
taproot
again these are very technical upgrades
to bitcoin
uh to operate you know sort of the
software itself but one thing that they
will be able to understand is that today
in bitcoin um different transactions are
like identifiable
so if you're doing like for example a
multi-signature transaction or you're
opening a lightning channel
or you're doing uh you're like mixing
your coins with someone else to do
what's called a coin join
these things are like you can look at
the chain and figure out what's what and
that helps chain analysis companies that
helps these spy companies figure out
what's going on
so after taproot a lot of these
signatures are going to look the same
right so that's going to be really
really helpful for people who want their
own privacy
then there's going to be another upgrade
probably in a couple of years
and again a little technical but just
permit me for a moment here
which will do something called cross
input signature aggregation
which is a mouthful but it basically
allows like tons of transactions
uh to be accumulated into one in a way
that's cost efficient so here's the cool
part
it basically makes things like coinjoin
cheaper because like what would you
rather do
pay for 50 individual transactions or
just pay for one transaction
so the funny thing is if if this happens
in the future
it could could totally happen two to
three years exchanges and corporations
may be financially incentivized to
implement privacy meaning if they're
trying to like
basically uh make a payment out of their
treasury
um or or you know batch sell or batch
buy or whatever they're doing
it is actually going to be cheaper for
them to do something that's similar to
like a coin joint basically mix
everything together
um and the fact that that's like
going to be something they want to do
not out of altruism not out of a love
for human rights
not our love for privacy but simply to
save money is freaking awesome and this
again this goes back to this game theory
in bitcoin where
it turns your self-interest and greed
honestly
into privacy and freedom and you see it
again and again at every different level
so basically to sum up for your
listeners bitcoin is programmable it's
becoming more private over time
and the wallets and apps that you use to
interact with it
are going in a direction where they will
allow you to leave less and less of a
digital footprint
which is the total opposite of our
current surveillance capitalist model
where whenever we do a swipe or a tap or
one day like a chip scan as we talked
about last time
um you know you're serving up on a
platter to like third parties and
governments like your freaking address
and your email
your phone number and everything about
you and your whole family right so
here's our chance to say like enough of
that um
let's make a different kind of payment
system for the world where we can
protect at least some of our rights and
liberties right
and again the only way to make this
happen is through core developers
who have to just sit there and
relentlessly tweak with the code and
make sure it doesn't screw anything up
because at the end of the day what we
prize most in bitcoin is stability
we're never going to have an upgrade
come on that we're not all 100 percent
sure
is not going to mess with the monetary
policy it's not going to mess with 21
million
etc so that's uh basically my way of
saying
uh privacy is happening it's happening
because of these great people
and and you all should support it but
even if you don't want to support it
you're going to be forced to support it
anyway because it's going to align with
your uh
your your financial interests absolutely
last thing i want to talk about is
regulation there's been a lot of talk
from all kinds of people but
mainly investors coming from the
traditional world that
uh bitcoin will be regulated bitcoins uh
kind of original promise of this
decentralized private world
uh has no shot of being successful but
if you're here for the financial returns
then you actually want it to be adopted
in the traditional system you want it to
be um regulated
etc how do you kind of think through
this idea of
bitcoin will be regulated versus uh what
i'll kind of call the the bitcoin
promise of a private decentralized
um world yeah this is huge and it's it's
what people are debating right now
as we head to the end of the year in
2020 um there are two major reasons for
that
one was a bill um a draft bill a very
early draft bill introduced by some
folks in the modern monetary movement uh
under
one of the us congressman's women's
umbrella essentially and the bill was
about stable coins and basically about
challenging libra okay which is fine but
there's part of the bill
that basically leaves the door open for
uh you know you maybe to be liable
for any transactions that that go over
your node
if you're running a software like
bitcoin uh or ethereum right
and that that is very dangerous right um
i mean that's not
that is absolutely not it's it is nuts
the funny thing also is like if you want
to stop libra or any of these stable
coin projects
that is like the hardest and last thing
to do is like 6102 the population you
know what i mean like that's
and i'm referring to uh the act which
basically allowed the us government to
go collect everybody's gold back in the
30s okay
you know 6-102 but um no that's that's
so freaking hard and difficult and
obviously violates the constitution
if you want to stop a stable coin
company just seek a polite meeting with
their investors and the team making the
freaking stable coin
and ask if they can do it differently
and if not go ask the us government to
force them to
i mean all of these stable coins are
made by a company or by
or are ruled by like a bunch of people
who are oligarchs who kind of hold
these like governance coins so you don't
need to
do this this is an insane step in the
wrong direction
um but it raises the point that like
there will be increasing
interest from the government in
regulating these things now of course
they're going to be look they're going
to be much more interested in regulating
stable coins than bitcoin at first
just because stable coins literally are
like representations of the dollar so of
course the us mint is going to want to
be interested in that like
of course um but eventually they're
going gonna get real interested in
bitcoin as well currently we have a
surprisingly
cordial relationship i would say between
bitcoin and the us government
especially given the efforts of all the
good folks in wyoming right i mean
they're making it possible for for banks
to custody bitcoin on behalf of users
and you're at like the cutting edge of
all that and you know how
surprisingly rosy it all is and in terms
of
what what someone like me might say is
like this crazy cypherpunk tool
you're you know you got you know you
guys mainly are are you know and again
for good reasons looking at it as an
investment class and you want to make
sure as many people as possible can have
access to it just wonderful
and a big part of bitcoin's narrative
but you can't really have both
you can't have one without the others
what i'm saying um so
i would say that we need to be concerned
about these new acts as they come in
but let's also be realistic um the way
that we're gonna fight them is not
through lobbying i mean
we can start social movements and you
know we can we can apply pressure
sure it works from here to there uh it
works at times
but generally speaking the way that
we're gonna win is
through open source software okay so we
need to take lessons
from the crypto wars of the 90s right
where the us government through various
actions tried to basically ban um
you know end-to-end encryption and they
went after this guy phil zimmerman who
had created
uh you know pretty good privacy or pgp
which was like the first time you could
do like public key encryption on a pc
right so they went after him but you
know what they lost and encryption ended
up becoming a core part of our
commercial infrastructure
a core part of the com boom the ability
to do encrypted payments on the web
a core part of everything and now today
you and i can talk on signal and the us
government doesn't know what we're
saying
right so that's pretty amazing and that
all happened
um not because the us government was
lobbied into thinking it was a good idea
but because they literally failed to
regulate what is
unstoppable code basically right so now
we have bitcoin
and they are also i would say it's
unlikely you're going to sway them to
think that this is going to be a great
thing for them because it's not
um i think there's a lot of great
organizations that are going to like
help protect
americans rights like coin center right
in this area they do awesome work
but remember like most countries don't
have a coin center coin center would be
like illegal
in like 90 countries so you know it's we
have an
extra responsibility here um in
countries like the united states
to fund bitcoin core development help it
become a privacy tool for everybody else
there's a good podcast recently where
moxie marlon spike was on joe rogan
um moxie of course created signal um
it was also a new yorker essay on him
recently and you know signal is such a
wonderful tool for the world and such a
you know wonderful thing for human
rights activists right however we need
to remember that it was created in the
united he was created primarily in the
united states
um or by someone who lives in the united
states is primarily his brain
child right and he's been able to
develop that in a way
where the us government hasn't shut it
down or hasn't tried to shut him down
right
so you know he couldn't have done that
in china or russia et cetera et cetera
so people in open societies we really
need to take our responsibilities and
privileges seriously
and we need to double down and help make
sure bitcoin is a tool that can actually
help people who live in these other
countries
where they're not going to be able to
lobby for better policy in the future
they're not going to be able to protest
their government to protect financial
privacy
it's not happening in saudi arabia uh
you know or in nigeria
uh or in north korea it's just not not
happening so we need to take it on
ourselves
to do more stuff like the bitcoin
development fund and like the
what what the what the winklevosses are
doing with their opportunity fund and
with what square's doing with square
crypto and with what companies like
blockstream
are doing and what chain code's doing
and look there's so many good actors in
the space now right
we need to seek to replicate and double
down on these efforts not just for
ourselves but for everybody in this
world
yeah it feels like we're really
seeing kind of a line drawn in the sand
we either pursue policies
or we can pursue technology and history
would tell us that
pursuing technology will trump pursuing
policies that doesn't mean that pursuing
the policies isn't
important doesn't mean that we shouldn't
push back when uh there is frankly
misguided uh or
just flat out stupid legislation that is
put forward um but at the same time the
technology component of this is one
really important but also two
uh kind of has the final say right
because if there is technology that is
built that can't be
uh regulated i think that that has been
a part of the world that most people
have not understood
uh but now very quickly is starting to
understand and uh
not only one is it exciting but two is
uh it can be the great equalizer for
people around the world whether they
have a voice or not
um because ultimately that code can can
really kind of
open up opportunity uh and make it much
more prosperous safe world for people
everywhere yeah i mean just to recap
policy reform and technology are both
very important
but remember billions of people in this
world in fact the majority of the world
population
cannot do policy reform so their only
option is technology
they're not going to get a central bank
digital you know they're
going to get a cbc that protects their
privacy i don't personally think we're
gonna go
either but it's on the table it could
happen potentially
um it could happen in switzerland it
could have been sweden it could happen
in canada
again i don't think will but it's not
impossible i mean
we could have cbdc's that protect
privacy maybe
but again for the billions of people
live in dictatorships they're never
going to have financial privacy through
government choice
okay they're never going to have their
government come out and make a tool that
protects their financial
privacy never so that's why bitcoin is
so so important as this like
decentralized
monetary effort that we can all
contribute to and get involved with
and that's something that i hope that a
lot of these people who are
you know kind of making waves lately
with comments about how
you know bitcoin has to adapt to the us
regulatory environment
they need to do a little more research
and a little more global thinking about
about
about their philosophy i think and
these people aren't human rights
activists so and i don't expect them to
be
but i think they need to have like a
global context of what like
what they're saying will mean right
because you know i'm talking
specifically about people like ralph
paul
and michael saylor i mean they're
basically saying that hey for us to
succeed for bitcoin to get to every
corner of the earth
it has to be something that is legal in
the united states and
you know and that you know sort of like
um you know meets all the demands of the
regulators here
but again they have to realize most
people don't live in the united states
and like
if you seek to like co-opt bitcoin and
like make it regulatable here
think about what that means for people
abroad right this is
a luxury for them like bitcoin for them
is a luxury they have beautiful homes
one guy lives in the cayman islands like
what do they care i mean they're like
hanging out
okay great okay bitcoin is like a luxury
for them bitcoin is life or death for a
lot of people around the world it's like
their lifeline it's like the only way
they can have money that doesn't
disappear or get seized it's the only
way they can send money
to their family if they're working in a
different country sometimes it's the
only way they can get
money to somebody so they can buy
medicine in a sanctioned country
so this is like some serious stuff here
um
and no it's not gonna like comply with
your rules and regulations
so that's just something that you have
to kind of think about and
be careful because again you can't just
come in and like
say you're you're you know you think
bitcoin should do x
so that more investors can have access
to it in the united states this is like
a global global tool
for the world and you have to think
about all the perspectives
of all the people who will need to use
this thing yeah
where can people find out more about
human rights foundation and if they want
to either learn more about the privacy
components or
potentially donating as well to some of
the things you guys are working on
sure um please visit us at href.org
again most of our work relates to direct
support for people who live under
authoritarian societies
whether in the form of legal campaigns
advocacy
conferences tech support um but we do
have this like again this really
fun project that i'm very proud of
called the bitcoin development fund
where you can donate to us and and we
will
uh put 95 of your donation directly in
the pockets of
bitcoin developers working to make the
network more private more free
resilient usable for for people around
the world so that you can check out
specifically
href.org slash dev
fund and um just very grateful for the
opportunity to come on and talk about
these things with you pop as always
you you have an open invite whenever you
want to come on and talk i'm i'm always
here
and uh people know that i don't really
talk too much about what uh
what people should go do or look at but
i think the work you guys are doing is
uh
one just incredible in terms of uh the
non-bitcoin stuff and then obviously the
bitcoin stuff
kind of speaks for itself and so i
highly recommend people go check out the
human rights foundation
and all the great work that alex and the
rest of his team are
are doing thank you so much pomp we'll
be in touch